on a beau dire c'est comme ça la taille
ça compte et ça lui à tous les amis
c'est françois pour la chaîne explique
mme encore je suis ravi de vous
retrouver comme à chaque fois sur cette
chaîne où on parle de vidéo de caméra de
montage tout ça tout ça donc si c'est
quelque chose qui vous intéresse et bien
n'hésitez pas à cliquer sur le petit
bouton s'abonner un juste en dessous
voilà ça fait plaisir vous ne raterez
rien de la suite
et aujourd'hui on va parler de quelque
chose dont on n'a pas souvent parler sur
la chaîne justement à parler de guimps
bol de stabilisateur de nacelles en
français parce que vous n'avez pas pu
échapper à cette mode puisque c'est
quand même une petite mode 1 depuis un
certain temps on voit beaucoup de choses
shooté aux guiboles on voit beaucoup de
plans adverses mousse hyper stabilisée
on peu pas trop ou coupé aujourd'hui le
gumball ça devient un petit peu un
indispensable pas pour tous un pas
forcément utilisé en permanence mais
c'est un accessoire dont on peut
difficilement se passer aujourd'hui même
s'il existe des solutions alternatives
et quand on pense d'où on part un des
steadicam mais tout ça on se dit que
c'est des petits bijoux de technologie
quand même qui aujourd'hui nous
simplifie grandement la vie mais si vous
souhaitez vous équiper ya tellement de
modèles il ya tellement de marque
tellement de choses différentes
tellement de fisher proposées par les
différentes dit mme paul que je me suis
dit que c'était intéressant de faire une
vidéo alors pas forcément de ré view de
produits même si ici on va en comparer
deux mais plus pour vous aider à choisir
votre guillemoles en fonction de ce que
vous voulez faire
dans cette vidéo on va donc mettre côte
à côte deux extrêmes au niveau
stabilisateur le rhône un essai de dee
jay et le crane 3 s2a édition vraiment
on va dire les deux extrêmes de ce qu'on
peut trouver en termes de stabilisateur
et ça va être très intéressant de voir
un petit peu comment ils se comportent
et de voir un petit peu ce qu'on peut
faire avec pour choisir le stabilisateur
qui va vous corresponde le mieux et
d'ailleurs si vous voulez voir des
régions qui sont spécifiques à ces deux
produits mais je vous renvoie vers la
chaîne de stuc dessous chics à tester le
crime 3 s et la chaîne 2 litres turbo
d'arc à tester leur honneur
c'est dans cette vidéo on va s'attarder
sur comment bien choisir et du coup quoi
de mieux que de se mettre en situation
d'aller filmer à
ces deux petits guînes bol pour voir un
petit peu ce qu'ils font avec et on va
faire des allers retours entre ici et le
studio pour expliquer un petit peu tout
ça alors d'un côté on a le rhône un
essai qui pèse environ 1 kg qui peut
supporter environ 2 kg environ un peu
ceux de kilos déjà il va commencer à
tirer la gueule et qui est donnée pour
une autonomie de 11 à savoir que
maintenant le stabilisateur ont vraiment
d autonomie assez hallucinante quel que
soit le modèle de l'autre on a le crâne
3s qui pèse un âne mort vraiment
vraiment j'ai pas réussi d'ailleurs sur
le site a trouvé le poids du dean ball
moi comme ça au doigt mouillé je dirais
qu'ils pèsent entre deux et trois kilos
donc déjà rien de ça on est sûr d'une
bon poids mais par contre il a une
capacité de charge de 6 kilos et demi
donc ça veut dire qu'on peut mettre
jusqu'à 6 kg et demie de matériel dessus
et techniquement ils bronchera pas j'ai
pas essayé de mettre 6 kg dessus parce
que j'ai pas suffisamment de matériel
pour le faire mais il est censé comme
s'est montrée sur le site pouvoir
encaisser des raids des grosses caméras
de cinéma il est plus étudiée peau
vraiment du gros calibre on va dire lors
on a assez il coûte 360 euros et le crès
coûte 850 euros pour là aussi on n'a pas
la même capacité de charge mais on n'a
pas aussi le même prix on se retrouve
donc avec un rooney c'est très léger à
manipuler et un crime qu est-ce qui est
en gros tu la vois l'alter de 10 kg à la
salle de gym que tu que tu regarde de
loin
as tu la prend avec dès demain à bout de
bras du temps les bras et tu regarde
combien de temps que tu peux tenir à peu
près comme ça et ça donne une idée du
temps que tu pourras tenir avec le crane
dans les mains alors geneviève du coup
c'est le sc que tu préfères ce pas si
simple parce que lors on a un c'est si
je voulu mettre le z 6 avec le 24 70 que
j'ai mis là sur le craignent c'est juste
impossible
c'est des gens pourra pas l'équilibré ça
va pas passer ça va être assez compliqué
ça veut dire que pour bien fonctionner
le sc on va avoir une quantité limité
d'appareils qui vont passer dessus avec
différents objectifs qui vont peut-être
pas passer dessus si je veux mettre par
exemple mon alpha 7 3 avec le 16 35 est
de 8 sur le rhône et ses ça ne passe pas
c'est pour ça que du coup bah je lui ai
mis un à 6400 avec un 16 mm si ma dessus
ce qui fait que le poids est large
respecte et qu'on n'a pas de soucis
d'équilibrage et du coup ceux à 6400 il
reste fixé sur mon honneur et c'est donc
c'est bien mais j'aimerais bien avoir un
petit peu plus de choix sur les
appareils et les optiques que je
pourrais poser sur leurs menaces alors
un point hyper important quand on
choisit un game boy c'est l'ergonomie
déjà sur le crâne 3s moi ce que j'aime
beaucoup c'est cette prise à demain qui
est vraiment hyper pratique ne serait ce
que pour faire des ras de sol ou pour
l'obtenir
vu le poids franchement c'est pas du
luxe
1 mais si on avait eu ça sur le roannais
c'est ça aurait été encore mieux je
pense même s'il est beaucoup plus léger
a contrario le roannais c'est lui c'est
une prise classique comme comme une tige
qu'on va tenir avec les deux mains on a
moins cette possibilité de se reposer le
bras en laissant tout simplement tomber
un petit peu comme ça l'appareil et le
kin ball avec 17 double poignée qu'on
retrouve sur le weebe la baie le crane
trois là bas je crois qu'il s'appelle
ferdinand sont un peu compliqués chez à
une chose que n'a pas le rhône est assez
ou vraiment là on est limité à une façon
de le tenir qui est quand même assez
classique à demain on n'a pas deux
secondes poignet ou alors il ya des
choses en option mais là comme ça ça
reste très basique mais mais ça fait
tâche mais ça fait le taf alors l'autre
point qui est hyper intéressant qu'on
retrouve sur beaucoup de game boy
maintenant mais qui je pense est
indispensable c'est tout ce qui est loch
et qui vont permettre de bloquer les
différents axes duguine gaulle quand on
s'en sert pas quand on les utilise pas
et dans le sac c'est quand même assez
pratique parce que ça évite d'avoir le
gumball qui part dans tous les sens
voilà ça permet de bloquer de sécuriser
donc ça ça fait partie aussi des choses
qui je pense maintenant sont
indispensables sur le roannais sont les
a aussi sont un petit peu moins facile à
utiliser que ceux du craignent pour le
coup c'est un petit peu moins simple
mais ô ça marche tout aussi bien et ça
ça fait partie des choses qui je pense
sont indispensables quand vous
choisissez vos bingol essai sur
quasiment tout légume ball récent
maintenant de toute façon donc mais
vérifie juste qu'ils y sont qui a cette
possibilité de look et les différents
accents alors sur le dos il ya aussi
plein de modes plein de fischer on a des
mots des pv des modes vortex ya le
tracking sur le dj hi aussi si on est
son téléphone au dessus bon ça je suis
pas certain que ça soit quelque chose
qui puisse vraiment motivés
en achat ils font tous plus ou moins ça
a quand même un petit bémol pour le
craignent parce que pour changer les
modes il ya des combinaisons de touches
qui sont vraiment pas évidentes à
mémoriser
quand on est dans le feu de l'action se
poser la question comment je passe de
tels modes a tellement c'est juste hyper
relou alors que sur le run assez on peut
ce programme et sur des boutons de façon
très très simple via l'application des
modes qui sont voilà qu'on peut
récupérer en appuyant sur les
différentes touches c'est quand même
beaucoup plus pratique mais c'est mode
là au final ils sont un petit peu gadget
c'est parce que vous allez utiliser le
plus souvent est grosso modo un tous les
stabilisateurs ont à peu près les mêmes
modes les mêmes fischer à part l'actif
traque qui est vraiment spécifique du
coup au dj hype donc ce que je sais de
vous dire dans cette vidéo c'est qu'il
ya bien évidemment plusieurs tailles de
stabilisateur et que ça c'est une donnée
principal est hyper importante qui va
motiver votre choix d'achat c'est à dire
que si dans la plupart du temps vous
fait de l'événementiel si vous faites je
sais pas moi du mariage du corporel des
choses où vous devez avoir votre
appareil dans les mains toute une
journée ou même avec le stabilisateur
il ya bien évidemment le craignent 3 s
on n'oublie pas ce qu'une journée à
moins de s'appeler hulk et d'avoir des
drags comme ça et pas un dos en carton
comme moi c'est juste impossible vous
allez vous tuez les bras et vous tuez le
dock l'a clairement que le crime 3 s
on oublie le et c est beaucoup plus
indiqué par contre sur des situations où
on a plus de temps où on va pas ajouté
forcément très longtemps on va pouvoir
faire beaucoup de pauses on va laisser
le stabilisateur dans un coin le prendre
juste à certains moments parce qu'on en
a besoin
là le crime 3 est ce qui peut avoir son
intérêt mais clairement posé une raide
dessus c'est comme ça qu'il est
mark était entre guillemets ça n'a aucun
intérêt et je vois vraiment pas pour
avoir discuté avec des gens qui ont des
rêves des grosses caméras gardisme
impossible quel intérêt de poser sa là
dessus donc le truc le plus important à
mon avis quand vous choisissez votre
guînes ball et ça n'engage que moi c'est
mon avis le truc le plus important ça va
être l'usagé que vous allez en faire et
en fonction de ça le poids que va peser
ce guillemot moi je me suis détruit mes
petits bras
voilà je suis pas un grand gaillard avec
certaines guiboles est vraiment à me
faire mal sur des tournages toute la
journée
au point que j'avais plus du tout envie
de les utiliser
j'en étais arrivé à un point où je
détestais les guiboles je suis toujours
pas hyper fan du truc je les utilise
mais vraiment quand j'ai pas d'autre
choix
la plupart du temps je m'éclate beaucoup
plus à main levée plutôt qu'avec le king
ball mais il ya des moments c'est
indispensable et ce qui moi me fait
pencher pour le rhône et à cesser ce
côté léger ce côté facile à utiliser on
a un accessoire en plus mais il n'est
pas handicapant dès qu'on part sur du
plus gros j'ai du mal
c'est pas forcément votre cas vous avez
peut-être d'autres besoins tout
simplement le cren s est un très bon
football qui cherchent un petit peu sa
cible on sait pas trop qui va l'utiliser
et pourquoi mais ça reste un bon game
boy à condition d'avoir des gros bras et
d'être un grand gaillard
voilà si si vous êtes un adepte de la
salle de muscu le crime 3 s vous foncez
c'est juste génial si vous êtes un petit
peu plus comme moi lors on a assez ou un
rônin s bref quelque chose d'un petit
peu moins lourd un oui bilabo si ça peut
être vachement bien ça sera beaucoup
plus intéressant parce que dites vous qu
au delà des phisheurs ce qui va vous
gonfler le plus quand vous utiliserez
votre guillemoles c'est de vous y péter
les bras et le dos et ça on le dit pas
assez
ça on ne dit pas assez c'est même pas la
taille qui compte c'est le poids c'est
le poids les amis et on en arrive donc
au moment les amis où il faut mettre le
coup de blaster sur le pouce en l'air
qui situe juste en dessous de cette
vidéo pouvez également vous abonner si
c'est pas déjà fait aller voir d'autres
vidéos qui s'affiche ici
et puis je vous dis comme d'habitude
rester curieux et à très bientôt pour
une prochaine vidéo